- Welcome back, yeah we've
got Eric Stonestreet here.
Give it up.
(audience clapping)
- I'm still here.
Still here.
- So still here.
- I haven't left yet.
- Still.
I won't let him leave.
- No.
- So we were talking about
your engagement earlier, right?
So how did your "Modern
Family" co-stars kind of react?
'cause you're on a show that long
you built such relationships
with these people.
- [Eric] Yeah, there they are.
- [Kelly] Were they like
freaking out for you?
- Aw.
(audience clapping)
Well they were very happy when
Lindsay and I started dating.
I mean, I think, I was the
kind of the last holdout,
everybody else had, the
adults had partners.
And when I met Lindsay-
- They were adulting?
- Yeah.
(Kelly giggles)
And when I met Lindsay and
started bringing her around
everyone was just in love with
her right from the get go.
So when I asked her to marry
me, they were very excited.
And of course, Julie,
once when we were out here
she's like, "I'm coming
over to see the ring."
And she was very interested.
- Hold on, she said the ring.
- [Eric] Oh God, yes.
She's like that's what she
needed to see right off the bat.
- [Kelly] I love it, I love it.
- It passed her inspection,
which if it passes Julie's inspection
and Sophia's inspection,
- You've nailed it.
- you're good.
- I love that.
I just, it's always good,
I feel like to have your
friends' approval of people,
they can, you know?
- Yeah.
- Sometimes you have blinders
on, but they'll point it out.
That's awesome they loved
it right off the bat.
That's important.
- Yeah they loved it.